Hi, Steve Kaufman here.
Today I'm going to answer the question.
How do you become good at
speaking in a language?
What's the secret?
And I'm going to share with you
the secrets about getting started
speaking in a language and how
you continue to get better and
better at speaking in a language.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
And by all means, join me at LingQ,
which is  where I leare languages.
Now, you have all heard
me talk about input.
I stress input.
I say you have to get the language in you.
You have to acquire words.
You have to let your brain
get used to the language.
And that's how, that's where I spend
most of my time, but I do want to speak.
We all want to speak.
That's the goal for most of
us of learning a language.
We want to communicate with
people, to connect with people.
We want to express ourselves
in the new language.
So how do we do it?
And people have asked me sort of
specifically to go through sort of
step-by-step because I know that many
of us, and myself included, after an
extended period of input, of listening
and reading and acquiring words and
seeing my comprehension, you know, improve
and I understand more and more stuff.
And then, you know, I schedule a
session with a tutor and of course
I'm concerned like, how am I going
to be able to retrieve these words?
You know?
Oh, by the way, I'm wearing
my t-shirt from Machu Pichu.
And it relates a little bit to
my story and I'll get to that.
At any rate, you know what
happens when we start speaking?
How do we get started?
And that's what I want to kind of cover
in this video, sort of getting started,
speaking in a language and then doing all
the things you need to do so that you can
continue to get better and better, even as
you continue all of your input activities,
even as you continue to acquire words
and phrases and, and, and, um, get
your brain used to the new language.
So you all know that I spent
most of my time on LingQ.
On LingQ of course we have
all of our input activities.
We also have tutors.
We don't have as many tutors as
italki, but we do have some, and the
advantage at LingQ is that the tutor's
report is incorporated into LingQ.
So I have a record, all of,
of, all of my conversations
with my tutors now in Persian.
I'll give you an example.
So Persian and Arabic, both
very difficult because the
writing system is so difficult.
So what I did in order to break down that
first barrier, in other words, I have
never said anything in Persian or Arabic.
How do I get started?
How do I get words out?
Now, there are people who say
that you can talk to yourself and
you can say phrases to yourself.
But I've never found that I'm
able to do that for very long.
I might try it, but I won't
spend a lot of time doing it.
It's just something that I
have never been able to do.
People who can do it, good for them.
It's a way for them to prime
the pump, to get started.
What I found and what I recommend, what
I found very useful was in languages
like Persian and Arabic, especially,
but probably in all languages,
I get a tutor, whether on LingQ or
italki, and I say, I want to read and
what I, and I, I want to then talk about
what I have read and what I use as the
sort of material that's going to prime
the pump and get me going is the mini
stories, because the mini stories have
so much repetition built into each story.
And I end up listening to each
one of them, 10, 20, 30 times, not
necessarily at one sitting, but over
the course of a couple of months.
I will have lesson two, lesson one, two,
three, four, five, back to lesson one.
And so I'm familiar with what's there and
in each mini story, there are questions,
but the questions are structured in such
a way that you are given the answer.
In other words, a statement, you are
asked the question about that statement
and then you're given the answer.
So you don't even have
to provide the answer.
It's just more exposure.
But now with my tutor, I am asked
those questions and I have to produce
the answer, but I am producing an
answer that I already know, that I
have listened to many, many times.
So, the big thing about
speaking is to reduce stress.
In fact, if there's one
key it's to reduce stress.
Stephen Krashen says that we learn
languages when there is meaningful
communication in a low stress or
unstressful environment or situation.
So anything you can do to reduce
stress is going to help you.
So, first of all, if you have a tutor,
you're with someone who is paid to
speak to you, so that's less stressful
than hoping that some random person you
meet is going to want to humor you in
your, in the language you're learning.
So that reduces stress.
Even amongst the tutors, some
are more sympathetic than others.
Some make a face if you say
something wrong or show impatience,
you don't want those tutors.
You want the tutor that's very
encouraging, doesn't correct
you all the time, uh, and
keeps the conversation going.
But also by sort of having a pseudo
conversation where I'm asked questions
that I have heard before and where I have
in fact read the story with the tutor and
maybe even read some of the questions,
and then I'm asked the
question, I have the answer.
I'm not asked to remember
something about the story.
I'm just asked to say something
that I've heard before and.
You know, it's very familiar to me.
I'm likely to succeed.
Whenever you're given something
to do where you're likely
to succeed, that's good.
The brain likes it, likes success.
Doesn't like failure.
So I find that beginning to speak in
the language, uh, reading and then
discussing, using the questions that are
in the many stories is extremely helpful.
And so I would recommend that as a sort
of step number one, where you, you got to
break the ice, you've got to go from all
of your listening and reading to, to a
situation where you're starting to speak.
And what I found in both Arabic and
Persian was that I would do that for
three or four or five, six lessons.
And then I was tired of doing that.
Now I wanted to, even within
the 60 minutes, I might do
that for the first 20 minutes.
And then I would start to wander off
into something else, perhaps using
the vocabulary that I had learned.
So it's, I'm sliding into sort of a
broader range of, you know, exchange with
my tutor all in a low stress environment.
So that's extremely important.
The next thing is obviously, when
you start to speak, part of the
stress comes from your inability
to say what you want to say.
Part of it comes from not understanding
what the other person is saying,
because you're not good enough
in the language to have a really
good, free-flowing conversation.
Bit of advice.
Don't worry about what you can't say.
Don't worry about what
you don't understand.
And there is a bit of a
tendency for people to wonder
about what people are saying.
Like I, often people ask me, well, have
you ever been in an elevator with Asian
people and have they said stuff about you?
Never.
People don't talk about you, but it's
when you don't understand you conjure
up these ideas that people are talking
about your, what are they saying?
And, and I've often as I'm progressing
in a language when I was learning
Portuguese I'm with these Brazilians
and they're all talking a mile a
minute and I feel I should be able
to understand, but I don't understand
because my brain is not yet used to it.
And you have to remember that with
enough exposure, you will get better.
And so every time you're in a situation
where you don't understand, or you can't
say what you want to say, that's fine.
It's part...
you're on your way.
That's part of the process,
uh, of, of getting to know,
you know, acquiring a language.
And when I was in Machu Picchu,
I was with these other people.
And our guide was speaking to me in
different languages and they were a little
bit annoyed that the guide wasn't speaking
in English, they were annoyed that they
couldn't understand what he was saying.
Don't worry about what
you can't understand.
That's very important.
So begin with a mini stories, reading,
answering questions, where you have
the answers, where you've actually
heard the answers many, many times
then gradually move to subjects
which are of greater interest to you.
But I would recommend staying with people
who are paid to be sympathetic to you,
like a tutor or a teacher of some kind.
Uh, if you, like I mentioned, when
I was learning Japanese, I had a
very patient assistant, um, Mr.
Nick Yazaki, who was very
long-winded and spoke very,
you know, humored me and stuff.
If you have people like that,
fine, but don't put yourself
in stressful situations.
Then just keep on speaking.
Keep on, uh, finding there again, find
a tutor who's good at keeping you going,
who can ask you questions about things
that you're interested in, where you're
going to succeed, who doesn't insist
on, you know, like I've had tutors that
they just, they want to talk about food.
I don't know the words for
food in let's say Persian.
I want to talk about history, which
is of interest to me, but my tutor,
she didn't want to talk about history.
So get tutors that are sympathetic,
that don't express annoyance when
you make mistakes and who are good at
keeping the conversation going around
things that you are interested in
and where you can express yourself.
Then of course, when I get my conversation
report at LingQ, I study it, I listen
to it many times, and I remember the
things that I had trouble saying.
And if I look at a number of these
conversation or parts and listened to
them, I realize that I made the same
mistakes week after week after week.
It doesn't matter.
You have to have confidence that
you are gradually going to improve.
So the answer, how do you get started
speaking and continue to improve?
Reduce the stress, reduce the stress.
Start with something like the mini stories
where you're basically reproducing things
that you have heard many, many times.
And from there gradually wander
into a greater range of subjects,
subjects that are of interest to
you, with someone who is sympathetic
to you and, you know, gradually
your ability to speak will improve.
And in the end, as I've said, many
times, even though I stress input, to
speak well, you have to speak a lot
so that, uh, I find that I'm speaking
with a tutor once or twice a week, you
know, at the early stages, maybe three
months after I started into the language.
But eventually if I want to do well
in the language, I may eventually have
to go to the country, but I also ramp
up, you know, my, my sessions with my
tutor, maybe four or five times a week.
So there you have it, my take on
how to get proficient at speaking,
which is something we all want to do.
And how do we do it in a
way that minimizes stress.
And I'll leave you with a
couple of videos that might be
relevant to you on the subject.
Okay, then bye for now.